[Music]
Reeta inland loud senior are the parents
of eleven loud children their family is
watched by tons of fans around the world
some fans have noticed that the parents
aren't all they seemed to be stick
around until the end to see which parent
fans think is downright rude if you love
the loud house give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things to stay up-to-date now
let's jump into why the loud house
parents are the worst
is anyone supervising Lucy Lucy loudest
eight years old at her tender age she
claims to be a huge fan of HP Lovecraft
Lovecraft's works are dark twisted and
wildly inappropriate for a child that
age any parent should be alarmed to see
their child reading such advanced and
scary literature where did Lucy even get
access to love crafts works what
librarian checked her out with those
books
who would sell them to someone that
young you have a lot of questions about
what she's allowed to read slips of you
turn clumsy fingers into glue and it
doesn't stop there
it seems everything Lucy loves isn't
even close to age-appropriate any parent
should be concerned about such a gloomy
kid Lucy is so cynical
she doesn't have the happy attitude
you'd expect from a kid that age she
needs someone be helping her work
through all of these feelings where mr.
and mrs. loud when Lucy is getting
involved in spooky occultism it's great
to embrace their kids for who they are
but Lucy might need a little extra
supervision Rita and Lynne senior don't
seem to be around too much with eleven
children it must be impossible to spend
quality time with each child every day
poor Lucy seems to have fallen through
the cracks
why isn't money getting any help though
thou children have a really wide range
of talents and abilities with eleven
kids it's not surprising that they
represent a lot of different levels of
intelligence some of the loud kids are
obviously gifted or very bright money is
not one of them at 16 he lives-- work is
a six piece puzzle that's still
unfinished
shouldn't it be alarming to her parents
Lenny is one of the most charming kids
in the family she's positive and
supportive of her siblings
lynnie has a lot of fans but some have
criticized how she's treated it seems
like the Louds just don't take Lenny's
problems very seriously anytime lynnie
seems to be catching on slowly the
family treats it like it's an endearing
trait it's important to be accepting and
kind when someone is struggling it's
also important to encourage your
children to be their best Lenny is so
talented that we can't help but feel
that she's capable of more fashion
design isn't simple and it takes some
serious creativity and brains if money
isn't secretly clever how can she be
such a great designer
Lenny clearly needs some kind of support
she isn't getting we hope she gets it
soon and finishes that puzzle too much
stuff not enough attention the Louds are
obviously very comfortable with eleven
kids they can still afford a nice home
each child is well dressed well fed and
has no shortage of toys someone is
providing Laurie with a cellphone a car
and car insurance packed a lot of
expenses the loud kids all seem to be a
little spoiled when it comes to their
possessions no one in that huge family
is suffering from a lack of clothes toys
or gadgets there's nothing wrong with
showering your kids with gifts lots of
people express their love by buying
presents the issue fans take is that
presents can't replace quality time with
your kids
fans have noticed that Rita and Lind
senior don't show up very often they
seem to leave the older kids to look
after the younger ones quite a bit
that's not uncommon for a large family
it's healthy for everyone to pitch in
and help out it does seem a little odd
how rarely the loud parents are around
we didn't even see Rita's entire face
and tell the second season the loud
seemed to lavish their children with
gifts but they don't seem to spend a lot
of time with them we'd love to see more
episodes with Rita and Lynne senior
hanging out with the fam skinny dipping
the grown-up blouse certainly acts like
they're still in love it's good for kids
in two-parent homes to see that their
parents have a stable relationship it
can create a feeling of security and
promote family harmony
we're glad Lynne senior and Rita's
seemed to be so close sometimes that
romantic playfulness can get them in
trouble in the episode sweet and sour to
loud parents booked a vacation at a spa
resort
they're thrilled to
some time alone for the first time since
1998 the kids are upset to learn about
the vacation they don't want to be left
out they also don't want to stay with
their aunt Ruth the kids convince their
parents that they'll be good and they
end up getting invited to join them on
the trip at the resort the kids
predictably caused quite a ruckus they
shut down the elevators disrupt the TV
signal cut the power to most of the
resort and make the pool corrosive all
of that is before they flood their room
and burn a hole through the floor one of
the kids goes so far as to impersonate a
hotel employee
yikes as you might imagine the family
are asked to leave it's later revealed
that the real reason they've been kicked
out is that Rita and Lind senior were
caught skinny-dipping in the pool is
LuAnn crying out for help
lots of people use humor as a coping
skill it's normal to crack the
occasional joke when you're stressed out
it can be a really healthy forum of
stress relief even healthy behaviors can
become a problem when they're compulsive
fans have noticed that Luann's obsession
with comedy might be a cry for help what
could be a normal hobby or even a future
career seems to be a compulsion her
jokes can be inappropriate at times
she's been known to make wisecracks even
in serious situations making jokes at
the wrong time isn't a great way to win
friends it can be rude and hurtful in
the wrong situation we can't help but
wonder if LuAnn is using her jokes to
get attention is she feeling a little
neglected when her parents aren't around
maybe she's acting so silly to hide
sadness it's impossible to know for sure
but any good parent should pay attention
to this kind of obsessive behavior LuAnn
may have a bright future in standup if
she deals with her inappropriate timing
no one wants to get their feelings hurt
by a badly timed joke here's hoping
LuAnn gets whatever she's acting out to
get we'd love to see her timing improve
the but obsession is out of control we
get it butts are funny but the loud
house takes the obsession a little bit
too far there are a ton of rude jokes
and potty humor on the show how can we
forget the time Laurie farted while
doing yoga or Lin's epic Dutch oven
gross not to mention Lincoln and Clyde
burping and passing gas in the woods at
least there were no innocent victims
around at the time the loud house has a
lot of inappropriate moments lots of
people love a good gas joke but how many
is too many
the obsession doesn't end with
embarassing sounds or smelly humor the
entire family can be observed
triumphantly shaking their booties
without family victory dance is silly at
best may be rude at worst as a mom Rena
should probably discourage this kind of
lewd shenanigans instead of discouraging
her kids from shaking their backsides in
each other's faces she joins right in
what kind of mom says that example we've
got some questions kids will be kids and
silly antics are to be expected I guess
we expect an experienced parent to at
least try to rein in the chaos Lincoln
gets the short end of the stick when you
have 11 kids it's really hard to make
sure each kid gets a fair shake for
Lincoln loud it seems almost nothing is
fair he's vastly outnumbered with ten
sisters that alone would be enough to
win him some sympathy
unfortunately for little Linc it seems
his parents aren't trying very hard to
level things out on his behalf the loud
family seems to cater to the girls fans
can't help but notice that Lincoln seems
to get blamed for a lot multiple times
Lincoln has been pointed to as the cause
of his sister's bad behavior they even
rope the poor kid and when their fights
and mischief have nothing to do with him
it really does seem like he's being
unfairly bullied involved parents should
step in if they notice when child being
picked on more than the others sibling
rivalry is normal Lincoln is the only
boy in a house full of girls it's
natural for there to be some friction
fans everywhere feel like someone needs
to stick up for Linc
his parents are an obvious choice to be
his best advocates what are Lind senior
and Rita doing that they don't have time
to stick up for their son someone needs
to notice this bullying and shut it down
we hope mr. and mrs. loud step it up and
make sure Lincoln gets a fair chance
they aren't as smart as their kids it's
every parent's job to look out for their
kids parents are supposed to help their
children make good choices and develop
common sense
really hard to do when your kids are
already smarter than you to be fair some
of the loud children are clearly
geniuses Rita and Lindsey near proves
just how gullible they are in one
episode in particular in no such luck
Rincon is declared to be bad luck by his
sisters what begins as a simple
superstition becomes a hurtful and
ridiculous exclusion mr. and mrs. loud
plan a beach trip for the rest of their
kids but tell Lincoln she's not invited
you're bad luck Lincoln you can't it's
one thing for children to believe in a
silly superstition but for parents to
mistreat one of their kids over some
perceived bad luck is a little much we
expect better from grown adults poor
Lincoln always seems to be the butt of
the joke his parents should really come
to bat for him more often it's
disappointing how easy it was to
convince them that he was bad luck
The Vow parents rarely step in when
their kids have problems could that be
because the kids are more capable than
they are do they recognize that they're
outwitted by their children too much
independence not enough support kissing
a little room to grow it's important to
let children grow up and develop their
own independence it's hard to feel
confident on your own if you don't get a
chance to fail and learn it's also
important to give kids enough support to
develop that independence safely many
fans have observed that mr. and mrs.
loud seem to prefer that their kids work
out all of their problems on their own
they don't appear in many episodes of
the show and when they do they choose
not to help out even when asked there's
nothing wrong with trusting your kids
but where are Rita and Linn senior all
the time it's important to model good
problem-solving skills it's impossible
to do that if you're never around
it seems like the loud children are left
to sink or swim on their own most of the
time thankfully they seem to always come
out on top we'd love to see their
parents take a more supportive approach
there's nothing wrong with offering your
kids a little help now and then the loud
kids can be rowdy and out of control but
there's still good kids and deserve the
support of their family it's obvious the
lads love their children they just need
to be a little more present Lynne senior
is kind of
mean in most families with two parents
one is more strict than the other in the
loud house that parent is definitely mr.
loud Lynne senior has been known to step
in and shut down the chaos when his kids
get well loud in sleuth or Consequences
Lincoln is blamed for clogging the
toilet to be fair he has a history of
doing it no dad for real it was not me
though
Lucy was the real culprit Lincoln took
the fall for his sister to save her from
embarrassment mr. loud was a little
harsh on his only son and ended up
grounding him for a simple mistake he's
demonstrated that he doesn't want to
accept the only loud boy for who he is
he was angry when Lincoln preferred
video games to working out and is
disappointed that he isn't an athlete
Lincoln has his own personality and
deserves to be accepted for who he is
Laval dad is a mischievous guy and has
been known to pull pranks on his kids
son pranks are harmless fun but it's
kind of mean to trick your own kids
pranks aren't the end of his gruff
antics when the family decided Lincoln
was bad luck they went so far as to kick
him out of the house and give away all
of his possessions that's just plain
mean mr. loud very obviously loves his
wife and children he makes jokes with
LuAnn goes on frequent dates with Rita
and spends time with his huge family he
just has a few rough spots we hope you
enjoyed these fan theories and
observations we'll see you next time
[Music]